[Applause]
portraits are shred the funny line
between a fiction and a reality
[Music]
so when we're on the streets it's
completely random of course and that's
that's part of the magic of making these
portraits is you can't predict what's
gonna happen just sort of be aggressive
stop the person be honest tell them what
you're gonna do and if their game their
game not let him go wish him a good day
[Music]
you can't stop they're not coming to be
photographing real fast make a portrait
of you you look great
not my face not your bag I'll stay close
up how's that I might start a little at
a distance but I might get then
attracted to something really up-close
maybe do some framing and composition
and see what happens
you want to make that person comfortable
and you have to do it pretty fast it's
already weird enough to be up in your
face with a camera let's try and
minimize the awkwardness you don't mind
that these guys shooting here do you
they're gonna take your head put it on
naked body he's cool we're gonna do
weird porn probably wired I got a big on
the board overcome your shyness you need
to be photographed
thanks to seconds coming come and make
it a portrait won't only think it works
eight seconds you're gonna stay in here
just looking at me like that my no smile
no smile just looking it right in there
is it disappointing sometimes when a
remarkable character walks by and denies
you the chance to be put to be
photographed yeah sure but again you
inter just internalize it and bring that
energy to the next person who does pose
people like to be photographed if they
pose if they've stopped
more than likely they're cool of being
photographed what they're not
necessarily accustomed to is the super
close and I like it up close
the camera is just a tool to sort of
express your vision don't get hung up in
the gear I use one lens I use a 50
millimeter lens and that's it I want to
get close I am close then SLR is handy
camera wise because it allows for you to
control a little more exposure but if
you're a adept enough at Photoshop or
something you can do a little of that
clean up make sure that white is really
white after the fact I think a lot of
photographers get hung up on this idea
that you have to construct the image
that it has to all be pre-planned that
you have to light like crazy I'm outside
could it be better light sure but we're
not going to get hung up in it the real
magic is the interaction I'm not really
interested in the golden gate one of the
people what's your name I'm Frank gonna
meet you my name is clay so because
we're dealing with natural light there's
a few things to pay attention to and one
is to find that open shade you don't
want direct Sun it's just gonna blow out
your exposure in it and it's not as
flattering also you want to find
evenness and right now it's a little
darker on this side than it is on this
side so I'm compensating a touch ideally
for me I like a really really flat light
the sky is your soft light and so just
work with it in a more shady area you
might want a little bounce in there to
fill in the eyes this isn't an exotic
setup I mean literally some white paper
and some natural light and you got
you're in business white
I like black is cool too but white is
something sort of simple and clear and
classic about it it's okay to direct
it's okay to move them around
a little bit I'm trying to also make
them look strong and and you know heroic
if you will and I don't mean that my
superhero sense though you could take it
that way it's that I'm really trying to
put them in their best photographs you
make are uh are not just the person he
stops but the total cumulative
experience and all those people who
passed you by as well
[Music]
[Applause]